we're back with another to guest episode
of the Microsoft Research podcast this
time featuring the co-founder of the
artist-in-residence program along with
MS ARS latest artist in residence
together they discussed their current
collaboration ada and inspire us to
think big about the future of human
driven AI fuelled
cyber-physical architecture you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen heusinger Jenni
Sabin is an architectural designer a
professor a studio principal and MSRs
current artist in residence Oscar rose
Way is a principal research designer of
fusionist and the co-founder of the
artist in residence program at Microsoft
Research the two along with a stellar
multidisciplinary team recently
completed the installation of ADA the
first interactive architectural pavilion
powered by AI in the heart of the
Microsoft Research building in Redmond
on today's podcast Jenni and us to talk
about life at the intersection of art
and science tell us why the artist in
residence program pushes the boundaries
of Technology in unexpected ways and
reveal their vision of the future of
bio-inspired human centered AI infused
architecture that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
I am thrilled to welcome two guests to
the podcast booth today to celebrate the
launch of ADA an AI powered
architectural Pavilion in the lobby of
Microsoft's building 99 with me today
are Jennie Sabin and Oscar Rose why
welcome Jenny and hasta hasta and Jennie
to the podcast thank you thank you all
to be here so let's kick it off with you
Jenny I've already given a kind of a
list of what you do but that really
doesn't unpack it I'd like to hear more
from you what gets you up in the morning
when you're not creating art here in
building 99 what gets me up in the
morning really is the anticipation of
the day I engage in three integrated
roles sometimes more than that first and
foremost as an educator as you mentioned
I'm a professor of architecture at
Cornell University where I teach design
studios and seminars and our
professional degree programs as well as
our advanced degree programs with a
focus on emerging technologies and
design and issues of making and digital
fabrication and more specifically
looking at how collaboration across
disciplines impacts the way that we
think in the architectural design
process related to that I run a lab a
Saban lab within the College of
Architecture and planning where I
collaborate with a number of scientists
material scientists biologists engineers
where we together innovate new materials
and think about how buildings perhaps
could behave more like organisms
responding to their environments and to
people most importantly and we also
think about innovating new digital
fabrication protocols across multiple
length scales and I engage a number of
students and senior researchers in my
lab thirdly I am principal of Jenny
Simon studio which conceptually is very
linked to the topics and ideas that
we're pushing forward in the research in
my lab but it's the entity where I'm
able to
take on applied projects to really push
scale to take on Commission's and to
engage in incredible opportunities like
this participating in the
artist-in-residence program at Microsoft
Research and it has a different rhythm
in terms of what we're doing in
comparison to the lab yeah but that's
what keeps me going and keeps me busy
and also gets me up in the morning asked
is first of all you're a podcast alum
welcome back hi again Anna fusionist
here at Microsoft Research and for our
listeners who don't know what that means
they go back to episode 44 of the
Microsoft Research podcast and hear us
to talk at length about that but you
helped establish the artist-in-residence
program here at Microsoft Research so
tell us what it is why it exists and how
you go about selecting artists like Jeni
to collaborate with so the
artist-in-residence program is
essentially a platform that enables
researchers here at Microsoft Research
to collaborate to brainstorm to push
their technologies forward with the help
and aid of a creative an artist it sort
of helps diversify and push the
boundaries of the technologies they work
on in unexpected ways yeah and that's
really important because art is that
bridge into our humanity right so if
we're building these technologies that
have real-world impact it's essential to
have the right kind of brains in the
room and for artists to be able to use
art as a vehicle to envision possible
futures you both situate your work at
the intersection of art science and
technology and you both often connect a
few other streets and avenues to that
intersection like biology and
architecture and math talk about why you
both like this intersection and what
interesting things happen here that
might not happen elsewhere Jeni why
don't you give us a start well I think
for me at several different aspects one
is I've always been interested in both
math and science and the arts and for
many years I struggled to find the right
glove so to speak in terms of bringing
what are often seen as
desperate fields together and that's
what led me to architecture so I've
always been good at math and enjoyed
biology and the sciences but also
fundamentally I'm a maker you know I'm
interested in how these ideas and
technologies are made manifest in the
world alongside that in architecture you
know I was fortunate early on in my
graduate career when I was studying at
the University of Pennsylvania pursuing
my mark to experience the shift from
analog production of drawings in the
architectural design process to the
digital so I spent the first half of my
education producing drawings with AM a
line you know ink on mylar my god
which for me was a really great
transition and kind of segue from my
background in the fine arts to
architecture and then the second half I
was writing scripts and learning all of
these new processes and studying under
really important people important mentor
Minds sessile Belmond who I eventually
taught with and at the time we were
struggling with how to make sense of
these tools and how it was impacting the
design process and so terms like
complexity and emergence and dynamical
were borrowed by architects to try and
make sense of what we were seeing in
terms of form and I became a little bit
self-critical in wondering well maybe we
could actually learn some things from
our colleagues in the sciences about
these terms and that was a kind of point
of departure for some of the very early
collaborations and in forming bridges
with scientists was there any tension
I remember the shift from analog to
digital in music and there were the
purists who said you know digital I
won't say the word they said but they
didn't like it and they thought it
ruined music and the organic nature of
it so was there any of that going on oh
yeah yeah big time
but at Penn design I think it was a
pretty special place there was an
interesting critical dialogue going on
but there were definitely faculty and
also
students that were not so keen on the
shift that was occurring and also you
know and early on with my initial
collaborations with cell and molecular
biologists there were a lot of naysayers
you know sir what are you doing with
these biologists what do you know that
what a waste of time I want you to go a
little deeper to on this question of
that intersection of all of these
seemingly disparate areas I think
there's a lot more connection than we
may have given credit for in the past
boat yeah how do you find that playing
out in your own work so I have a very
kind of similar path to Jenni although
it everyone has different instantiations
of that but I also grew up in the analog
world Fine Arts my parents are artists
using my hands to create but then I went
into graphic design and that became the
digital world right and so you live
between these two realms and then you
come to a place along your path where
you're like but wait there are all these
other fields that are exploring and
using different tool sets to find things
so for instance in the case of detecting
pollution right we can build digital
devices to do that but you can also
augment chemistry to detect it too so I
think the appeal of new materials of
integrating that into practice is the
affordance of being able to explore
something beyond your standard
boundaries right right really pushing
that vision which is fun right if this
is why you work with new materials
because it affords you new shapes new
experiences new you know evolutions of
architecture that's why we do it here at
Microsoft - today we're talking about a
large interactive installation we could
call it art we could call it
architecture we could call it technology
and it's installed at one of the most
famous technology companies on the
planet I'd like each of you to talk
about why you think art is an important
element in technology and why in the
21st century technology is an important
element of art well I think
fundamentally art and design provide
openings and disruptions and new ways of
seen in the context of technology in
many ways I
to think about how what I do is not
about solving problems but generating
problems that we then you know look at
so it's important as a bridge it
facilitates new perspectives and
ultimately and with the case of ADA I
think it fosters research and
potentially opens up avenues and new
questions that otherwise may not be
readily at hand
hasta what would you add to that you
know essentially you know art affords us
kind of the new narratives so sometimes
like without art like you're just
thinking about technology for
technology's sake right and so when you
start to sort of bring in the creative
process you have serendipitous moments
and accidents happy accidents I like to
call them that actually enlighten
everyone involved in the project and so
in the case of ADA you have multiple
individuals who've actually risen to the
occasion to push beyond their comfort
zones to help instantiate something
novel and that's fundamentally very very
hard and difficult but it's so rewarding
on a soul level because you're pushing
out of your comfort zone and it really
goes back to that pushing yourself out
but also learning from others right like
we have learned so much from Jenny and
her process and how she thinks about the
world and how she puts it together and
she in turn has also hopefully learned
things from us and how we process and
digest the world and I think those
synergies is what elevates all of us ya
know I've learned so much it's been an
incredible journey
it really has it's like climbing a
mountain how well in that you just one
step at a time
mm-hmm and you're going up in elevation
and the higher you get you look down you
go oh my god like there's no turning
around we're going up right it's
reasonable oh yeah kind of kind of Jenny
there are a number of terms you use to
describe your work and the materials
that you use and they include things
like adaptive architecture bio-inspired
design material computation
amiable matter hosta you've used that to
you're a responsive materials this kind
of goes across both of your worlds they
invoke a non-traditional and sort of
counterintuitive way of looking at
things talk about how these concepts
inform your approach to academic
research technical innovation and
artistic practice you know in many ways
I think people when they think about
what the architect does they oftentimes
think about the napkin sketch what we
call the the party diagram that then
becomes a the big idea for the project
that you then design towards whereas in
my process which is where nature is an
incredible teacher I'm interested in
sort of turning that upside down and
saying okay what if that initial sketch
is emergent you know what if it can
change in the context of other
relationships whether those
relationships and constraints are coming
from materials or us as people or
environment and so I start every project
without any sort of preconceived idea as
to what the final form will be hmm and
that way of designing and thinking has
very much been informed by my
collaborations with scientists material
scientists engineers because you know in
nature geometry materiality issues of
context history program none of that is
separate it's all inextricably linked
and in the context of what we're
experiencing in architecture both in
terms of big data but also one of the
biggest paradigm shifts to hit us since
you know some people say since the
medieval period which is that the
architects being repositioned as a maker
again right so we can author scripts and
algorithms to communicate in real time
with robots 3d printers etc so our
former tools are notations drawings
planned section elevation and so on
those are still important but in a way
they removed the architect from the
process a sort of master builder right
and that's why I'm interested in biology
that's why I'm interested in looking at
these systems it's never been about
scaling up what might be a beautiful
form or a cellular form into an
architectural form but to probe what's
behind that image to look at the
processes and the behaviors that have
contributed to that morphology because I
think it's a really powerful way of
thinking in the context of this paradigm
shift and so the terms that you
described
they're terms to define the end products
or the end results of that design
process one of the things that you said
and this actually resonated with me so
strongly was knitting is computational
design and one of the first
instantiations of 3d printing as it were
talk a little bit about that whole
concept and what's already existing that
we don't even think about but we seem to
be wowed by the technological version of
it yeah yeah well in these concepts for
the route of the name of the project ADA
I mean one could say that netting is one
of the first examples of 3d printing as
you say additively layering link by link
row-by-row
material with an algorithm to begin with
with an algorithm I mean some of they're
gonna look at my sweater the same way I
mean some of the most amazing
computational designers that I know are
textile designers you know they
inherently understand a sense of
information and how zeros and ones are
coordinated into a you know a pattern
and an assembly and my mom is a weaver I
grew up around looms so that was
something that was a part of the
everyday but there's an incredibly rich
history between the mechanization of the
first looms the invention of the punch
card and how that influenced digital
space and so that just blows my mind you
know to think that something started out
as material a tapestry a knit that
ultimately influenced digital space and
the production of the first computers
[Music]
well let's talk about ADA because she's
our star today I'm calling her her and I
have permission to do that because it's
an incredibly feminine instantiation of
architecture and art and technology but
she's by far the most ambitious most
visible and most permanent because I
know she gets to live here for two years
mhm artist in residence project to date
because we're talking on a podcast and
this is a wildly and beautifully visible
installation I'd like you to describe
ADA for us visually and structurally who
is ADA what is ADA and how did she come
to life here in the heart of Microsoft's
building 99 well technology is
fundamentally human and I think in many
ways the big point of departure for ADA
is that we had a number of really
exciting and engaging and inspiring
conversations initially about artificial
intelligence and the possibility of an
architectural project bringing form and
space to that and making it playful
making it human and potentially kind of
shifting some of the more dystopic or
negative views of AI the kind of fear of
that technology into a paradigm that is
really about us and in our engagement
and so the spirit of the project is
really celebrating that and you know
data has incredible hidden structures
and oftentimes what may be intangible
could you know potentially be revealed
through our own direct engagement with
it and so the material systems the form
the way that the responsive materials
interact with light that is directly
driven in real time by sentiment data
being collected in the building that
coordinated choreography of data to form
to space to our own
sort of participation is really what
makes ADA a living architecture and you
know materiality is something that I
think is co-produced it's not just about
the materials responding but it's our
direct engagement with those materials
and the kind of magic that comes forth
from that I want you to imagine that I
can never get into the lobby of building
99 or that I can't see describe ADA for
me
so ADA is an ellipsoidal form it is
approximately two to two and a half
stories tall weighs just under two
thousand pounds it's suspended in an
area of the atrium a building 99 and
it's material systems entail an
exoskeleton composed of close to a
thousand bespoke 3d printed nodes that
are interconnected with fiberglass rods
that shift in diameter depending on the
forces that are traveling through it
that exoskeleton is then connected to a
fabric structure that's composed of
high-tech responsive fibers for example
one of the responsive fibers includes
photoluminescent thread which absorbs
energy from UV lights and once that
energy source goes away it emits that
light as knitted light so there are two
surfaces to ADA the outer surface that
connects to the semi-rigid exoskeleton
and a whole series of cells and
digitally knit cones that then form a
soft surface and so there are
opportunities to peer up through those
two surfaces and you'll see those
connections the kind of sinewy knitted
cones that structurally are acting as
Springs so the whole thing works
reciprocally and ultimately is suspended
so the exoskeleton holds up the fabric
structure the fabric structure holds up
the exoskeleton and then it's suspended
as I mentioned at three points within
the atrium and what's inside on the
interior of ADA is a large tensegrities
own that entails a sleeve of fiber optic
cable
bespoke fabric structure within a whole
network of LEDs that run not only within
the tensegrities con but also within the
network of the fabric structure and so
there are three scales of lighting that
are interacting in real time with the
sentiment data the data being collected
within the network of cameras throughout
the atrium and that data is then
revealed in various zones within the
project within the tensegrities cone
there's a single camera on the interior
of the pavilion that you can drive
directly and will override the other
cameras so that you have a sense of
actually really engaging with and
driving the project in real time Jenny I
want you to go back to these bespoke
nodes because hasta was telling me
they're all different how many of them
are there there's exactly 895 all right
so tell me your process with the math of
how this thing was conceptualized and
built yeah I should mention that there
is one axis of symmetry and so each node
has a partner so to speak in the project
but I quickly realized that if we were
going to make this exoskeleton work
reciprocally with the fabric structure
where you know every single cell or
knitted cone has a home within that
exoskeleton its surface design they were
going to have to be 3d printed and so
this is a big leap in my work from a
kind of technical and formal and
structural level there's there's a lot
of complexity in this project at many
many many many levels there are many
parts to this people you have no idea
yeah you know we spent months on just
the 3d printed node aspect of the
project doing mechanical tests looking
at what types of materials we would need
to work with I mean it was all you know
really cutting edge where did you land
with materials on those nodes they are
nylon hard nylon yeah so structurally
they had to be nylon and each one of
them has three numbers on it yeah so
each node has three numbers which Co
relates to
neighbor that it connects to so they
share a number and then it also relates
to the fiberglass rod link that connects
one node to the next so in terms of the
digital generation of the project ADA
would not be possible without the tools
that I work with and you know the
bespoke processes that were able to put
forward in terms of 3d printing and
digital fabrication and so everything is
parameterized so one thing that really
struck me about this process especially
when I and my team members were helping
sort of the installation process was how
physical math became like for me math
was always this thing that was a little
bit abstract and I have a little bit of
fear numbers so I'm just like okay but
but this process actually manifested
brought math into a physical form in a
way that gave me so much more
appreciation for the perfection and the
precision of math and what it enables in
a way that I wish I had had when I was a
kid because I think I would have gone
down a math road because I would have
been able to actually pair together the
creative vision with the way that math
you know enables that and so having
those nodes in my hand with the number
sequences I was like this is physical
math this is actually watching something
happen in the physical world which was
amazing it was really profound for me
hasta I want to go a little deeper on
the technical aspects of Ada and Jenny
you can pitch in here too because I know
you guys are collaborating at a deep
level but there's a lot of cutting-edge
research in ADA that comes from people
in this building so deconstruct ADA
technically for us and tell us how she
works yeah so ADA exists on a research
platform developed by Daniel Macduff
researcher here who has been working in
sentiment data analysis and he's
generated algorithms that can capture
expression variations from cameras and
infer a general sentiment from that so
like a frown a raised eyebrow a smile
and then
kind of puts that into a sort of a
sentiment state and from there we
translate that data into our PC our
servers and then that goes into our
Raspberry Pi infrastructures we have
about three that drive the LEDs right
and so Jenny and her team have defined
the color parameters of those sentiments
and then we've also created zones of
light that actually mapped to different
areas in the building where that
sentiment is being captured right so for
instance in our kitchens and anyone can
opt out and the data is anonymized so
it's just a general count right how many
frowns how many smiles and then you to
get an aggregate of that and then that
kitchen represents a zone on ADA and
then as jenny was inferring the par
lights below it are a kind of a general
a bigger side of those kitchens like
maybe half of the building kind of thing
okay yeah so you could have like the
angry zone and we had a happy zone
you'll see a streak of red go through it
and you're like whew somebody's not well
and as we noted sarcasm is not easy to
capture for humans even let alone
machines so it's probably I could fake
something and make the machine think
that I was happier than I was but and
we've also all had that experience of
walking by someone thinking of something
completely different and our facial
expression may read something but that
it's not yeah but that's part of why we
have this program right where this is
emerging area it's very early in its it
instantiations and this enables us to
sort of embed this into a form factor
that can actually be interacted with in
a way that isn't just a camera right and
so it opens up all these possibilities
these narratives like well what does it
feel like to have an entity responding
to you and responding to everyone around
it and be it controversial or not I mean
this is the reason why we need to have
art in the conversation because art is
fearless like that and those are the
conversations essentially that we need
to have right Jenny do you have anything
to add so you mentioned feminine that
ADA is feminine and you know I think
we're experimenting
a huge shift in architectural design and
the forms that are now possible with a
move from on a meta-level masculine
forms we're used to occupying spaces
that have hard edges Cartesian
geometries borders boundaries to one
that is much more feminine and in many
ways ADA celebrates that the forms are
more organic they're softer they're open
they're networks they're pliable they're
engaging and there's something about
that that we as humans resonate with and
I'm really obsessed with that space in
terms of how it can offer moments of
pause and delight and Wonder
well ADA is not just a beautiful work of
art she's a working research project
what are the core questions you're
asking with Ada and what do you hope
you're gonna learn from the ongoing data
collection analysis and even
visualization one of the exciting
aspects of the project for me is how it
may fundamentally support and inspire
and impact fundamental research that's
ongoing here in building 99 at Microsoft
Research and the architecture of ADA
both in terms of its material systems
it's responsive 'ti but also the
architecture of the hardware and
software is purposefully flexible to
allow multiple data streams to drive it
and so my hope is that researchers you
know here getting so excited about it
that they're like I want to test my data
with Ada and that's been happening has
it again we'll talk a little bit about
we've had a lot of people you know ask
Oh was there an open API can i plug in
my data set can I explore and that is
the whole point is that it enables our
researchers our engineers to live in the
material world with their data well
Jenny we're accustomed to describing
structures that have embedded AI as
smart buildings but another term I've
heard is something you call living
architecture so talk about how you
perceive the difference here
and what it might mean to the future of
architecture and technology even I think
that opens a number of questions I mean
one could say that ADA is embedded
architecture you know I'm really
interested in how as we move forward
materials and buildings potentially can
cease to be just things and elements you
know that we see and don't really
interact with but ultimately become more
like our own sort of cells and our body
is responding to and interacting with
affordances and our environments and
also with us you know I'm very
interested in how our code texture can
be made more personalized imagine if you
could generate a window on demand that
was four-year research project in my lab
with collaborators in materials science
and also alongside that what does that
mean in terms of large-scale
transformations of our building facades
in urban environments so go back to the
window on demand there are a lot of
places people work that have no windows
can you get a window on demand I mean
that's one of my sort of dreams the
responsive fibers and the interactivity
with light in ADA it's building upon
years of deep research into topics such
as structural color looking to nature
for models where color change and change
from opaque to transparent happen
through the interplay with light and our
own human perception and so when I
mentioned imagine if you could have a
window on-demand
it comes from a deep inquiry into these
particular materials where you could
dynamically switch from opaque to
transparent and so the interplay with
light with the photoluminescent fibers
for example builds upon some of those
concepts so I'm interested at a
fundamental level how we can design and
engineer materials to interact with us
and also their local environments while
at the same time limiting the amount of
energy that is input like interacting
with the Sun interacting with our
engagement with the materials you think
about how much energy is wasted to heat
our homes in winter for instance so if
you have a material substrate that can
actually generate its own heat and then
you don't have to have those other
dependencies like this is that kind of
world right that inspires us to also
think about how we want to move forward
with our own technologies I mean my hope
is that the next iteration of ADA is at
the scale of a building facade perhaps
here on Microsoft's campus ADA is a
hugely collaborative and
multidisciplinary project with many
teams involved as we've talked about I
want you to talk about the people that
were involved in this project who
brought what to the table and why was it
important to have a broad skill set and
perspective for ADA well I'll start with
my team at Jenny Saban studio you know
first and foremost we are a we you know
the whole sort of myth around especially
in architecture that a single person
authors a building is sort of ridiculous
but thankfully we're moving away from
that the people on my team dylan pranker
he was the project manager sort of
overseen a number of details and really
my right-hand person when I needed help
and assistance and without him I don't
know john Hilla
he assisted and led a number of
iterations on the design modeling so it
worked on design and production William
Ken he was a new intern in my office and
probably didn't quite know that he was
going to be dropped into the middle of
the ADA installation which he absolutely
was so thrilled about apparently I have
a reputation amongst my students who
they say you know Jenny people say have
you ever been on a Jenny Saban project
survivor you know because the projects
they always start out with a very
sophisticated digital investigation and
design process but there's also always a
very analog human component
and Jeremy Bilotti worked on a number of
aspects of the software pipeline working
with Daniel and myself so my team was
fundamental to pushing the project
forward in terms of working with
Microsoft Research I mean it's just been
absolutely amazing you know from the
beginning conversations with Austin and
Mira their excitement about working with
me and you know I think we just felt
like we had found kindred spirits and
really we have to do something yeah yeah
and early on you know the number of
different meetings I was able to have
with various researchers here in the
openness and excitement about you know
where we could go and what we could do
and then eventually working with Daniel
and then more recently with the
installation which has been intense
intense I mean that mountain and in all
of the you know the amazing ways and
also the moments where you're like wow
how are we gonna get to that next step
but to see everyone in the building and
my team just come together you know to
pull off the impossible it's been you
know a nice to talk about the people
here so on our side we have windy copper
who is a creative director for foundry
99 and also kind of our easy amazing and
Hulk smash Wendy and was able to really
project manage the complexities around
this project including working with the
City of Redmond working with our
building vendors and our engineers as
well as our communications department
like all those things
Wendy held that together and then
Jonathan Lester is a electrical engineer
in the medical devices group and he was
our head engineer on all things electric
electrical systems raspberry PI's
infrastructure he was the point person
on that and Daniel McDuff of course you
know built the infrastructure that the
data that drives Ada and Mira Lane who's
a partner in the ethics group also was
very pivotal in the beginning of these
conversations and how we could get this
far and what did you do you know what
like we were talking about before if
you Judas I just move between entities
and I try to remove obstacles I try to
reverse-engineer communicate between
different brain sets my role is to
engage our community to step up for the
call and the challenge and much like
Danny was saying like have you been on a
Jenny Saban project I get that
reputation here like have you worked
with Oscar rose way because it is truly
an adventure in addition to my team at
Jenny's Saban studio who are absolutely
amazing I've been fortunate to work with
a number of professionals outside of the
studio and also Microsoft Research and
so Clinton Binkley the structural
engineer on the project with Arup
without him you know it'd be very
difficult to pull off his expertise and
tensile structures as well as important
manufacturers that I have longtime
collaborations with Seamus Ikki and
Daisy in' and so on so to pull a project
like this off demands the expertise and
commitment of such an incredible diverse
set of people well it's time for what
keeps you up at night here on the
Microsoft Research podcast and ADA
couldn't have come at a more opportune
time given the nature of this
installation and other pieces and
devices that are endowed with sensing
technologies it raises some big
questions and I know that these are at
the forefront of everybody's minds what
are the conversations that ADA sparks or
even amplifies as we find AI research
heading ever-faster out of the labs and
into our everyday lives
well I think for me you know one of the
hopes is that it opens up a dialogue and
provides new questions around AI that
otherwise people might not think of as I
mentioned previously I think we early on
were very interested in how the project
could shift perspectives around AI from
the kind of fearful and the negative to
one that is fundamentally human Center
and positive and playful and optimistic
but I think we've been very cognizant of
the fact that there will be people or
visitors etc that maybe are not so keen
on what ADA is doing and opening up and
that's very valid and so those
discussions around the concerns the
excitement and so on I think are really
important and certainly things that we
shouldn't avoid right well what comes to
my mind and I'll say it out loud is
privacy and anonymity and what are you
going to do with my data and am I being
surveilled versus interacting how are
you addressing that right now well
importantly and this was from the very
beginning the data that's being
collected is anonymous and people can
opt out they don't need to participate
or people can opt in in fact you can
download the software that daniel has
developed on to your own personal PC so
if you wanted to take over ADA for a day
from your office Instagram feed only how
do you opt out well so in the way of the
stations that we've set up you can move
away from the camera and we have signs
that actually warn people ahead of time
like hey this is what we're doing and
we're being completely transparent about
it and if they choose not to they can
just move around the camera but here's
what I'll say there are cameras
everywhere
we carry phones in our pockets and this
is something we cannot avoid so rather
than pushing it away and pretending it's
not there
let's go strong into this and figure out
what it's about and where the boundaries
are and how to evolve that conversation
and so this is part of why we have the
residents because as I mentioned before
art has to be fearless art is the one
that's going to provoke the
conversations that actually need to be
had we're not hiding anything anybody
can interface with it and if they don't
like it that's a discussion we're gonna
have yeah I mean ADA it's fundamentally
about transparency
and you know the various platforms and
hardware that we all interact with every
day I would argue are not about
transparency not so to speak and so that
for me is a key difference you know
we're engaging the topic of artificial
intelligence and data collection that
bringing a transparency to it that's
about the production of new knowledge
and new interfaces and fundamentally
bringing it back to us as people I love
the fact that it's amplifying this
conversation in a pretty way not many
guests on this podcast were raised by
artists and both of you were which
explains a lot to start with tell us the
story of how you kindred spirits met and
how ADA unfolded from that meeting to
today I had seen Jenny's work years ago
and her work kind of crossed my radar
she had done an installation with Nike
that just it kind of burned a permanent
image in my brain and a few years ago my
colleague Marilyn and I attended a talk
at the U dub and Jenny was giving a
presentation Penn as she was showcasing
her work some of the images came up were
triggering in my mind like oh my gosh
this is the artist so I had an aha
moment because one of the things that I
have loved so much about Jenny's work in
particular is that it's a very fine line
between what you perceive as being real
and not real it's a digital material
hybrid when you look at those
photographs and actually you experience
or work in real life it is very blurry
those lines and I thought what an
amazing opportunity for a company like
Microsoft that just lives in the cloud
Ryan lives in the data cloud to be able
to partner with someone like Jenny to
play in those blurry lines between real
and not real
and so Mia and I both ran up to you
we cornered you we said you don't know
us but you will and how would you feel
about partnering with a company that
would you know help it instantiate the
notion of living architecture you know
with data and we are the data company
and what did you say Jenny oh yes yes
and I'm originally from Seattle
and alumni of the University of
Washington dogs which yeah yeah and this
fundraising event was a part of that and
I was invited by a former professor of
mine Jamie Walker who's now the head of
the art school at the U dub and you know
so growing up seeing you know the early
days of Microsoft and it was just like
this really amazing kind of full circle
return of many aspects of formative
years of my life so yeah many levels it
was a big yes with a capital y as we
close I'd like you to predict the future
not in the psychic sense but from a
practically predictive perspective
what's the future of ADA here at
Microsoft and what might the future of
ADA like installations at the
intersection of art architecture
technology and science look like
so I'll start as far as ADA's existence
here as I mentioned before the notion of
opening up an API that enables other
researchers and teams to explore their
data sets and augment ADA is kind of the
equivalent of growing up you know so
being a child going to adolescents going
into middle age it's a process we'd like
to see her have so for instance if we
have you know an augmented sound
experience we can augment with her over
time you know it also just opens up new
conversations and I think ADA deserves
to be able to evolve my hope is that
Ginny can build more evolved ADA's over
time in our new campus and that perhaps
the two entities could talk to each
other and have conversations based on
what
they're learning and understanding I
think every building is gonna want an
ADA to some extent so I think you're
gonna have some building envy but let's
just see how that goes
Jenny talk to us about how you see
things unfolding I know that you can't
predict the future but talk about your
vision for it well first of all I hope
that ADA eventually becomes a building
facade that would be my hope in terms of
its next instantiation everything the
relationships the platforms the
materials all of it could be taken to a
more permanent application as a series
of elements that composes a building
facade that for me would be really
really exciting because that ultimately
I'm interested in how these experimental
prototypes and spatial structures and
material systems impact our built
environments and facilitate more
personalized spaces that put the human
first in the context of architecture
which isn't always the case and so I'm
interested in how you know that in terms
of the future how architecture can
operate in a more evolving way so as I
was describing my design process where
the diagram emerges through
relationships that come into the fold
imagine if our buildings could also
evolve in that way and you know that's
where I go back to nature as a great
teacher contextual events environmental
conditions history program etc effects
form and I think know our buildings
won't be living growing literally moving
things but there could be aspects of our
buildings that do that and so the spirit
of ADA I think is a nod towards that
future but again really thinking about
how that is human driven and human
centric as a point of departure for
design and art
Jenny Sabin hasta rose white thanks for
coming on the podcast thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about Ada and other
artist-in-residence projects visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]